OK, Donald Trump's press secretary and senior
campaign adviser Kayleigh McEnany held a press
briefing yesterday and if anything has become
clear in the last five weeks, it's that she
is absolutely determined and committed to
going down with the ship in the most humiliating
way possible.
Kayleigh McEnany, you may remember it feels
like a decade ago, but it was not that long
ago.
I don't remember how long ago it was.
On her first day in the press briefing room
as White House press secretary, Kaili promised
the media she would never lie to them and
she would never lie to the American people.
But I know.
I know.
But she's she's done nothing but lie ever
since.
So let's look at some highlights or really,
I guess they would be lowlights from what
is closer and closer to being her last briefing
as White House press secretary.
She's asked the question understandably, logically
about the fact, and it is a fact that the
Electoral College has voted.
Will Donald Trump now acknowledge that he
lost, given that the Electoral College is
voted on Monday and without a shred of irony?
Kayleigh McEnany refer the question to the
campaign of which she is a senior advisor.
Remember that area?
Another viewer from college has voted as the
president acknowledged that Joe Biden is the
president elect.
Does he have any plans to invite him to the
White House?
The president is still involved in ongoing
litigation related to the election.
Yesterday's vote was one step in the constitutional
process.
So I will leave that to him and refer you
to the campaign for more on that litigation.
What is his reaction to Leader McConnell today
congratulating Joe Biden and calling him the
president elect?
I haven't gotten the president's reaction
to that yet, but the president, again, is
pursuing ongoing litigation.
I would refer you to the campaign for further
forward.
No more litigation.
It's the votes of.
I've been certified at the Electoral College,
has voted.
There doesn't seem to be a legal recourse
at this point.
The campaign would have more specifics for
you on legal recourse.
But yesterday was one step in the constitutional
process leading up to the January 20th date
in the Constitution.
This is such a tired, farcical game that she's
been playing.
If it's convenient, she's the White House
press secretary and if it's convenient, she's
the White House.
If she's the Trump campaign senior adviser.
And you're going to have to ask the other
entity about that, that that question.
It's actually completely embarrassing at this
point.
And she doesn't care.
She just keeps using that to avoid answering
questions.
No question is simple.
For Kayleigh McEnany, the answer is always
weird.
She was asked a pretty straightforward question,
will Trump take the vaccine?
And she says Trump is open to taking the vaccine.
Well, but will he take it?
We don't actually get an answer to that part.
Does the president plan to take the vaccine
and really do it in a public way to inspire
confidence among people?
So the president currently at this moment
has said he is absolutely open to taking the
vaccine.
He's been emphatic about that to me privately
and to you publicly.
But he did recently recover from covid.
He has the continued protective effects of
the monoclonal antibody cocktail that I mentioned,
and he will receive the vaccine as soon as
his medical team determines its best.
But his priority is front line workers, those
in long term care facilities.
And he wants to make sure that the vulnerable
get access first.
Yes.
Wouldn't you be taking the vaccine, set an
example for Americans to give them confidence?
Doctors, Dr. Fauci, as well as the month of
Celui, both said today that they think President
Trump should get the vaccine if they fail
because of the good for himself and be the
example.
Will he do that?
Why not do it to show Americans that it's
safe?
Because he also wants to show Americans that
our priority are the most most vulnerable.
There will be some senior administration officials
taking it publicly to instill that confidence.
It is very important.
This is not merely a cop out answer.
It's actually dangerous because Kayleigh cites
as a reason maybe Trump doesn't need the vaccine,
the fact that he had coronavirus and recovered
for it.
So he has naturally derived immunity.
That's still a question mark.
Why?
When you know that the followers of this president
are disproportionately anti science trump
brown nosers who will do anything they can
to excuse behaving less safely.
We don't know how long immunity lasts after
a recovery from the virus.
That's an open question.
We don't know whether you have stronger, longer
lasting, more robust immunity if you recover
from a serious case of the virus versus if
you had one of those asymptomatic cases.
We just these are open questions.
And it's irresponsible for her to be saying
that maybe Trump doesn't really need the vaccine
or needs it less because he recovered from
the virus, CDC guidelines and equivalent guidelines
around the world from from other country health
agencies are regardless of whether you had
the virus, when a vaccine becomes available,
you should get the vaccine moving on quickly.
Again says that Donald Trump will veto military
funding partially because he's angry at Twitter.
You know, when specifically when the president
will veto the National Defense Authorization
Act, when he's going to send the paperwork
over.
And why would he veto that, given the fact
that passed on veto proof majorities in Congress?
So he still does plan to veto the NDAA.
Don't have a timeline for you on that, but
he does plan to veto it.
He wants to make every effort to protect our
military men and women, and we'll prioritize
military funding in the big omnibus bill.
But he also has other important priorities
and I should say problems with the NDAA beyond
just the absence of Section 230 repeal and
beyond the inclusion of the war in amendment
one of the provisions of concern is troop
provisions about troop withdrawal and deployment
in Afghanistan, South Korea and Germany.
And so there are a number of provisions that
in.
So let me remind you about that.
Trump has talked about this Section 230 thing.
Section 230 is a provision which essentially
says that if there is illegal, libelous or
otherwise problematic content on a platform
like Twitter or YouTube, it is not Twitter
or YouTube that are liable.
It's whoever posts it that is liable.
And Donald Trump believes that if you eliminate
Section 230, a lot of anti Trump trends would
be shut down.
Like, for example, when Donald Trump said
at that tiny desk and attacked people on Thanksgiving
Day and then the hashtag diaper, Don trended
on Twitter, Dapper Don, sort of an allusion
to the petulant child that is Donald Trump.
Trump went crazy talking about section 230,
section 230, if we get rid of it, Twitter
would never allow diaper Don to trend.
Now, there's really no legal liability with
diaper Don.
Hashtag about not just a public person, but
one of the most powerful public figures in
the world.
So that actually wouldn't change diaper, Don,
from trending.
But what Trump seems not to understand is
that if Section 230 is eliminated, he likely
gets banned from Twitter because of the things
he posts to Twitter, which are wrong.
Public health.
This information, election disinformation
posts that direct bullying against individuals.
Trump seems to think his problems go away
if Section 230 goes away.
In fact, he probably gets banned from Twitter
All right.
So that's that's that to get back on track,
Kaili continues to allude to a second Trump
term starting on January 20th.
It's all coded language, but here she refers
to, listen, we're ready for a transition and
we're also ready for a continuation of power
and either might happen.
The Electoral College has voted.
It's over, but Caylee continues to to play
this game.
Biden's cabinet picks a president.
Trump had the benefit of the Senate starting
hearings and starting the process before he
was inaugurated in January of 2017.
Does the president oppose the Senate taking
up Joe Biden's nominees before the inauguration?
That's a hypothetical.
And he won't get ahead of that activity actually
happening.
But he has taken all statutory requirements
necessary to either ensure a smooth transition
or a continuation of power just absolutely
out of her mind.
There's no there's no caveat here.
There's no mitigating factor.
She's just pushing nonsense.
The Electoral College voted on Monday.
Joe Biden has 270, actually.
Three hundred and six electoral votes there,
gaslighting people.
That's all it is.
And they continue to raise money on it.
Trump as recently as yesterday, sending out
emails saying I need to raise a million dollars
in the next hour or day or whatever it was.
Caylee asked, why hasn't Donald Trump been
more visible during the vaccine rollout?
I mean, this is this is happening.
And shouldn't he be there?
We barely see the president.
Where has he been?
Is nothing on his schedule ever?
And clearly with a straight face says this
because Trump has been so busy working, why
hasn't President Trump been more visible during
this initial vaccine rollout if the vice president
in Indiana today was President Trump?
President Trump's been hard at work on covid
behind the scenes.
Just because you don't see him at the podium
every day doesn't mean that he's not aggressively
pursuing actions on behalf of the American
people.
He's briefed on covid regularly.
And I'm here speaking with you guys.
Others are outside communicating this information,
all the things she's talking about, working
behind the scenes meetings, working on covid.
His public schedule is blank every day.
It is the argument now, of course, when the
president there are things that are off a
president's public schedule that the president
does.
But is the argument that just like having
meetings about the vaccine are so secret that
they can't even be on Trump's schedule, it's
just more lies.
Trump is doing nothing.
Every report from inside the White House is
that Trump is doing nothing.
And then the sort of dénouement here as she
walks out is she she, of course, walks out
after taking very few questions and not answering
any of them in any real way.
You hear in this next clip as she's walking
out of the press briefing room.
I love this.
CNN's Jim Acosta asking, Carly, isn't it hypocritical
for you to accuse others of spreading disinformation
when you spread it every day?
A beautiful question.
Someone like Trump might call it a nasty question,
but it's an important question.
Take a listen.
Really interesting turn of events and good
for those who covered what was a story all
along and not Russia.
Disinformation.
Isn't it hypocritical for you to accuse others
of disinformation when you read it every day?
In a logical world, OK, if actions had logical
consequences, no one would want to employ
Kayleigh McEnany after this absolute insanity
of a White House press secretary tenure.
Unfortunately, we know that she likely is
going to end up with some kind of very cushy
gig either.
I don't know as a consultant that some right
wing organization or doing communications
for a company that has right wing leanings
or who knows, but she is going to have a very
soft landing.
Don't know if she should be unemployable based
on the deceit and the lies, but she's going
to have a fine landing.
If you were worried about where Caylee goes
after this, don't you don't don't worry about
it at all.
We'll have more coverage of this and clips
on the show's Instagram page at David Pakman
show.
And if you want to see what happened to my
umbrella in very, very powerful Boston wins,
make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
A video that has taken I guess I was going
to say the world by storm, not really a video
that has taken my followers by storm.
Me barely able to handle an umbrella in Boston.
The wind that's on my personal Instagram David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break.
Up next, Mitch McConnell, he finally did it.
What is it that he did?
We'll talk about it in
a few minutes.
The David Pakman Show
at
David Pakman Dotcom.